former teen mom star lane fernandez has
died he was 28 years old lane's death
comes just three weeks after he and his
wife kylie rose fernandez welcomed their
first child together kylie shared the
news of his death on monday alongside
sweet photos of lane and their newborn
son nolan she writes in the caption i am
so lost without you babe i love you to
the moon and back and i know you're
watching out for us i will forever miss
you it's always been you nolan emerson
and i love you so much and you are an
amazing father dog dad and husband
you'll forever be my rock and my best
friend i miss you more than anything
baby lane's cause of death has yet to be
revealed
lane's best known for his appearance on
seasons two and three of teen mom young
and pregnant alongside his ex mallory
beaver the two's co-parenting journey
with their daughter emerson played out
on the show
good lucky day free day
so
on monday mallory shared this old video
of lane with emerson on instagram with
the caption r.i.p she also posted this
sweet throwback moment with their
daughter writing this is how i want
everyone to remember him a happy father
and guy who tried to overcome all the
demons he faced he deserved so much more
life
same for me
[Music]
rachel beaver mallory's sister and
fellow teen mom star shared a tribute of
her own posting a photo of lane swimming
in a pool with emerson writing i can't
even begin to express the pain i feel
right now gone too soon rest easy
[Music]